well the Department of Homeland Security
is preparing to deal with urgent threats
on Election Day it is setting up a
virtual war room to help quickly
communicate there you see it and respond
to potential cyber security challenges
it involves partners from the FBI state
and local election officials and
representatives from the Democratic and
Republican National Committee's the
undersecretary for the department's
national protection and programs
Directorate Christopher Krebs is here it
is an interview you'll see only on CBS
this morning thank you so much for
joining us I know it's going to be a
very busy 48 hours for you yeah thanks
for having me good morning I want to
begin by asking you about the Boston
Globe story that is out this morning
saying that internal DHS documents
reveal that there are more than 160
reports of suspected meddling in the
last three months alone they say hackers
have had limited success in those three
months what can you tell us about this
report yes so that report is actually
it's a rollup of a range of reporting
that we've gotten from our state and
local partners I think the important
thing to recognize is in 2016 we did not
have good relationships with state and
local election officials and so when
they were seeing activity on their
networks they were not they didn't send
it to us so we didn't have a really good
over-the-top picture of what was
happening across the country we have
those relationships now the last two
years we've developed very strong
relationships we work with all 50 states
and a number of thousands of counties
and so they are sharing information with
us so when you talk about when you think
about this report that the Boston Globe
is mentioning that is again it's a
rollup of things that were happening on
a daily basis anyway scanning happens
every day on the Internet yeah yeah
interesting because one of the states
that didn't accept your help in 2016 was
Georgia secretary say Brian Kemp did not
accept your help at the time obviously
now there's a different headline coming
out of the state and inquiry now looking
into hacking what can you tell us about
the latest report there so we did get
notified by the state of Georgia
yesterday morning it's now as I
understand it a law enforcement matter
we continue to work with any state that
requests our services
we do work with all 50 states the
District of Columbia a range of services
so again anybody asks us for help and
we're there to support them yeah those
160 attacks the globe talks about are
they individual 160 different actors are
they coordinated and where they're
coming from yeah I'd caution to call
these attacks again scanning phishing
sorts of campaigns email those happen on
a daily basis across the the various
governments and private sector and we
certainly haven't attributed any of
those activities to a nation-state actor
but we continue to scour the globe for
any sort of activity in a nation-state
actor targeting our election
infrastructure so is that to say that
there are no nation-state actors
actively working on this trying to
interrupt or otherwise disrupt the
election so unlike unlike 2016 where we
had intelligence that the Kremlin and
Russia was attempting to interfere with
our election we don't have that same
level of understanding plus we're not
seeing these dedicated or known
manifestations of attacks from our
Russian adversaries but we are working
day-in day-out 24 hours to identify that
sort of activity and we do work with all
50 states right now again much much
different than the situation in 2016 so
Chris do you think the operations are
becoming harder to detect or you just
think maybe they're sitting this one out
or do you just think we're just getting
good and shooting it down before it
becomes an issue what do you think I do
think that we've gotten better at
defending our networks at working
together but I do think that the tactics
are evolving we have seen over the last
couple years in particular Russia be
very adept at using information
operations and influence campaigns right
now there is a lot of noise out there
there's a lot of noise and a lot of it's
garbage they're pushing messaging there
are reports about compromised systems
about the state of Texas those systems
being rigged for for voter fraud it's
just not true the the things like the
internet research agency like RT like
Sputnik they're pushing garbage so I
think when the American voter goes to
the polls tomorrow be informed be aware
go to your trusted election officials
your local election official the real
beauty of the system right
now American elections are run by
Americans they're close to 1 million
poll workers a lot of the times that
your neighbor
it's your Sunday schoolteacher these
elections are not run by the federal
government they're not run by the
Russians they are run by the American
public all right Thank You Christopher
Krebs thank you so much for joining us
on this election eve tomorrow a big day
for everybody thank you